[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE TEODORESCU: Hello,
and welcome to this module
on protected attributes and
fairness through unawareness.
My name is Mike Teodorescu.
I'm an assistant professor
of information systems
at Boston College, as well as a
visiting scholar at MIT D-Lab.
What this module
will cover will be
examples of laws that codify
protected attributes, as well
as the base case
scenario for fairness
in machine learning,
which is called fairness
through unawareness.
The use of machine learning
presents both risks
and opportunities.
Machine learning
can reduce costs
by automating repetitive tasks,
but could also increase biases.
Certain individual
attributes are commonly
labeled as protected
attributes, as they
can be sources of social bias.
These are race, religion,
national origin, gender,
marital status, age, and
socioeconomic status.
In the United States,
discrimination
based on these protected
attributes in housing, lending,
and employment is illegal.
Some of the laws are listed
here for your reference.
However, regardless of
the legal framework,
machine learning still
has the potential
to unintentionally embed bias.
In this lecture, we
look at a few examples.
The next lecture will
explore some approaches
to mitigate unintentional bias.
Even large companies could
unintentionally discriminate.
For example, Amazon
used a machine
learning algorithm
to screen resumes,
and later found out that the
algorithm was discriminating
against female applicants.
In another example, this time
from the criminal justice
system, machine learning
is used to determine
the risk of recidivism.
This system has been questioned
in a variety of studies,
in particular, with
reference to the protected
attribute of race and gender.
In another example of
a large organization
employing machine learning,
this time, to display ads,
Facebook has been named in a
suit over alleged violations
of the Fair Housing Act.
Therefore, even
large organizations,
like Amazon an
Facebook, find machine
learning fairness challenging.
We hope this course will
be helpful in preparing
software engineers to better
address machine learning
fairness.
Generally speaking, before you
implement a machine learning
algorithm, you need to collect
data to train that algorithm.
This data set would have
your outcome variable,
in this figure, Y, for
example, the decision
to hire or not to hire, as
well as all of the predictors,
for example, features
collected from resumes.
This complete data
set would then
have to be split in a training
set on which the model would
learn and a test set on which
we would determine the model
performance.
There are other details,
like cross-validation,
which we'll not
cover here, but I
encourage you to read more on.
Fairness starts with a
good quality training set.
Low quality data,
generally speaking,
leads to bad predictions.
The individuals
labeling the data,
for example, managers labeling
resume as a higher or no hire,
may carry biases, which
are then picked up
by the machine
learning algorithm.
Training data may not be
representative of all groups,
which could lead to bias.
And there may be hidden
correlations in input data,
for example, between a protected
attribute and the predictor.
That can also lead to bias.
Individuals labeling
the training data
may misremember past
situations, a phenomenon known
as selective perception,
which may in itself become
a source of bias.
The default fairness
method in machine learning
is fairness through unawareness.
Fairness through
unawareness refers
to leaving out protected
attributes such as gender,
race, and other characteristics
deemed sensitive.
And, while it was thought
to erase inequality,
it was found, actually,
to perpetuate it.
It may do so by, for example,
having other attributes that
are correlated
with the protected
attributes in the data, which,
by ignoring the protected
attributes, we could just
still include in our model.
This could actually
perpetuate inequality.
When race, gender, and
other sensitive variables
are treated as protected, other
variables, such as college
attended, hometown, or
other resume indicators
that remain
unprotected, may still
be highly correlated with
these protected attributes.
Thus, ignoring the protected
attributes altogether
may not reveal these hidden
correlations in data.
This is called
redundant encoding.
In one example, researchers
at Carnegie Mellon University
found that gender caused
an unintentional change
in Google's advertising system
such an ad listings targeted
for user's seeking
high-income jobs
were presented to men at
nearly six times the rate they
were presented to women.
This may be an example of
fairness through unawareness.
Here are some review
questions about this material.
What are the
sensitive attributes
in the context in
which you work?
Do you think that the current
list of protected attributes
is exhaustive?
What is fairness
through unawareness?
What variables might lead
to biased predictions
for a machine learning hiring
system in your country?
What are some risks to
an organization choosing
unawareness?
I'd like to thank my co-authors
Lily Morse, Gerald Kane,
and Yazeed Awwad
for a study that
helped me put together
also these slides,
as well as USAID for a grant
on appropriate use of machine
learning in developing
countries and the Carroll
School of Management at Boston
College for research funding.
I'd also like to thank
everyone who helped contribute
with feedback to these
videos, as well as
the accompanying manuscripts.
I'd like to share with you
some references I found helpful
[INAUDIBLE] this material.
I hope you will read
more about this,
and I'd like to thank
you for your attention
in watching this video.
Thank you so much for
watching this video.
We hope you find it
useful and you'll continue
watching the rest of the class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]